oh dude everyone's talking about this
[__] fight that happened with the uh
boat what white guys were on a boat and
then black guys were on the other boat
and then the black guys came to defend
the other black guy and people are
making like his racing it probably it's
probably a little I don't know if it is
this one goes back to what I was saying
dude people just don't like differences
if you're fighting a guy who looks
different in your head you're like [__]
this [__] whatever he is I don't
care what color creed religion too bad
you didn't put down some of the pizzas
you might have been a [__] a little
bit better with it pop right I don't
hate fat people but right now I do right
because I look at what the difference is
between us
so now a black guy comes or now an Asian
guy comes in oh [__] he's racist but
really that's just the difference
between us is that I can't be
blindfolded with dental floss and it's
so stupid dude I'm a [__] [__]